Friday night Nakia Aldridge a 32 year
old woman living in Chicago was shot and
killed while pushing a stroller in what
appears to be a negligent or accidental
shooting in the sense that the shooters
were aiming for a different man and she
was caught in the crossfire it just so
happens that 32 year old Nakia Aldridge
is the cousin of NBA basketball star
Dwyane Wade who tweeted about the
shooting over the weekend saying my
cousin was killed today in Chicago
another act of senseless gun violence
for kids lost their mom for no reason
unreal
hashtag enough is enough Donald Trump
wanted to tweet about this also but
apparently to make some kind of strange
point about black people voting for him
and it might actually be his most
senseless and bizarre and offensive to
many people tweet yet he tweeted Dwyane
Wade's cousin was just shot and killed
walking her baby in Chicago just what I
have been saying african-americans will
vote Trump just what I have been saying
what what has he been saying exactly
they have nothing to lose there's no
nothing they could lose potentially by
voting for Trump things can't get any
worse vote for Trump he actually took
the tweet down a few minutes after
putting it up and people thought oh wow
Trump thought better of it and said this
is actually a completely insensitive and
offensive tweet no he took it down
because he had misspelled the name of
Dwyane Wade which makes it more amazing
he put the tweet up took it down and
then still thought it was such a good
idea that he corrected the spelling of
Dwyane Wade and put it back up an
innocent woman is dead right children
have lost their mother a family is
grieving and Trump is sort of bragging
about how this death makes it so his
electoral performance is going to be
better all the time meanwhile where the
right says that Democrats should stop
politicizing gun deaths
what is Trump doing here this is the
height of exploiting a tragedy it's not
the first time that Donald
Trump has done this after the Orlando
nightclub shooting he basically came out
and said see I was right
right about what who knows I mean what
does it even mean Jason to say this is
what I've been talking about that
there's gun violence that black people
will vote for you if anything bad
happens to them even if that has really
nothing to do with President Obama but
the permissive gun laws that we see
everywhere around the Chicago area I
think it just shows his absolute
disconnect with society and people in
general he has no humanity to him who
who in the right mind would say this
never mind
in person on the internet wherever is it
possible he thinks of this as outreach
to black people because he thinks oh
what was a black person died I've been
saying black people should vote for me
therefore I will tweet now black people
will vote for me I've admit maybe he's
so deluded that he thinks this is a way
to actually show that he would in some
way be good for the non-white
communities of the u.s. I'm really
trying to rationalize what cannot be
rationalized here yeah this is as close
as he gets to you know being humanizing
and connecting with black people in it I
think it goes further to show the point
that he's not actually trying to connect
with black people he's trying to connect
with certain white demographics to make
him seem like he's not a bad guy that's
right where he's gone with this I think
Dara Lindh wrote an article saying
exactly that which is this newfound
attempt at outreach to black people
which of course as we know I can't
imagine would convince a single black
person to vote for Trump it's more about
appealing to the moderate white voters
who have been turned off by Trump's
insane bigotry and racially tinged
language because you're not going to
convince any black people to vote for
you with this type of rhetoric but if
there are white people who don't like
Hillary and they hear anything remotely
approximating concern for the black
community that's really who Trump is
probably speaking to here and I think
you're absolutely right about that Jason